yes you know it's a very it's a very
very Christian some people think about
things like that I I unfortunately I'm
very mom an engineer you know i'm i'm
always thinking about you know what's
the task and how do i get it done and
some of my tasks are pretty broad and
pretty fuzzy and pretty pretty funky but
but that that's the way i think now how
would I I mean I guess the way I would
think that through they answer your
questions I don't have an answer so let
me think about how it would have an
answer would be I would ask myself what
are the real puzzles that that I I truly
don't understand and I think are really
really important so you know I let's
just go back to those those big issues
that I that I described earlier so so
I'm really puzzled by why people in
societies find it difficult kind of to
work collaboratively together with other
people in societies so I'm not sure I
know who the right name is to pick
interview but but I I think I don't know
whether it's religious leaders or
whether it's some of the few political
leaders that have risen above the the
kind of you know special interest
politics I mean I'm bad at coming up
with names but I think that would be
that would be one of the interviews you
know I'm also fascinated by the the the
sort of sort of deep psychological roots
of of how a lot of these phenomenon that
I'm interested actually play themselves
out so you know I recently came across a
body of work a guy named Daniel
Seligmann i think is his name it pant
and he's his work is labeled under the
phrase positive psychology and and and
and and his his whole body work is how
you can get people to kind of you know
pursue their positive positive interest
in
and and work constructively and and so
you know there's there's a great
interview what have we learned about how
to get people to bring out people's a
positive side in their better side and
their constructive side as opposed to
their fearful side or they're jealous I
door there you know dot dot dot side so
those are just don't just a couple of
examples one specific of the other more
kind of a generic category but you know
I got to tell you even for somebody like
me who is very broad in my interest and
and and i truly engage you know many
parts of the world it there's so much to
know these days that that it's hard to
you know keep exposing yourself to these
new bodies of thought and feels that are
but i think over time as my work
develops i suspect that to make the next
set of breakthroughs one's going to have
to intervene tagaytay collage achill
theories and thinking and understanding
with some of the more if you will
rational an organizational and economic
in order to address some of the very
vexing questions that either ask how do
we talked about earlier
you